do we scroll scroll scroll um
john eastman is in the news you can see
this here um
there's a new article in the national
review where john eastman
is trying to
uh distance himself from his memo that
he wrote for grandpa poopypants to
overthrow the government of the united
states to attempt a cheeto dust kangaroo
coup now john eastman says nope no that
i was just kidding it was all [ __ ]
it was all [ __ ] no one would ever
believe that right no one had ever
believed that this sounds a little alex
jonesy and infowarsy you know like when
they denied that sandy hook happened and
they sicked all the all their [ __ ]
right-wing
crazy-ass whack-a-doos on the parents at
sandy hook
and they they
they harassed them for months and months
and months and years
uh after the sandy hook shooting
they killed their children
it kept harassing them these people had
to move out of state and change their
all kinds of [ __ ] that they had to do to
get away from these alex jones infowar
wackadoos
and alex jones goes to court and says oh
that's all an act that's on act
no one would ever believe that that that
i would when i say stuff like that no
one would ever believe that kind of
stuff
ever no one no one could possibly in
their right minds believe that [ __ ]
for them to stoke to to harass parents
of a school shooting where their little
children were killed
well this is the same [ __ ] [ __ ] same
goddamn [ __ ] john eastman's trying to
pull here they're trying to whitewash
and trying to change what happened
you can't you can't change
the [ __ ] the truth you [ __ ] idiots
john eastman developed a memo for
grandpa poopypants
so that he felt good about overthrowing
the constitution of the united states
and demanding that mike pence do it for
him you know because he he never can do
[ __ ] for himself i mean [ __ ] he can't
even pour a diet coke for himself i'm
sure he doesn't even unwrap big macs by
himself he probably doesn't take him out
of the box
you know he eats [ __ ] big macs and
double fish sandwiches but there's no
way the guy the guy unpacks them someone
unpacks it for him probably probably
even cuts it into pieces for that
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
that whiny little [ __ ]
maybe maybe he eats his [ __ ] big macs
and his double mcfish with a [ __ ]
fork
it's not a mcfish by the way is it
it's a it's a filet
but he gets double fish sandwiches and
big macs and diet cokes maybe someone
even holds the [ __ ] straw for him
because that's what john eastman was
doing here
john eastman developed a memo
to make rudy giuliani
lynn wood sydney powell mike flynn
and the delusional grandpa poopy pants
the ability to say yeah yeah i can oh
yeah we can overthrow don't worry you're
gonna be you're gonna be the president
you're gonna be the president grandpa
poopypants don't worry
don't worry you whiny little [ __ ] we'll
make sure that you feel good all the way
up till inauguration day
we'll make sure of it
now john eastman doesn't want anything
to do with this [ __ ]
he says nope i don't want anything to do
with it
i don't want anything to do with it so
now he's trying to change in whitewash
history here
he's trying to say what happened on
january 6 where he stood on the [ __ ]
stage him and rudy giuliani stood on the
stage and and and
parroted and trumpeted what his memo
said
right before they went
the mob
the violent insurrectionist the
seditionist
the cheeto dust confederacy
went and tried to violently overthrow
the government of the united states on
january sixth
that's what happened while you had
eastman
giuliani
steve bannon who's now held in criminal
contempt of congress we'll see if the
doj charges him officially
but they voted last night to hold steve
bannon and contem
criminal
contempt of congress
but that's what this is it was a cheeto
dust
kangaroo coup
and john eastman was one of the cheeto
dust generals of the of the cheeto dust
confederacy
that's what
it
was john eastman doesn't get to change
this and neither does the the the
institution where he works either oh
it's no big deal he was kidding
he's being sarcastic
he's he's not responsible for making
sure that uh that a mob got out of
control and wanted to violently
overthrow the united states government
possibly possibly hang the vice
president united states and kill nancy
pelosi and other democrats and other
congressional leaders
now that's all that's all hogwash
just ignore that no big deal
and [ __ ] you national review for playing
into this [ __ ]
completely playing into it you can go
read the article but and they tr they
try in the beginning to say oh this is
what happened but they're giving they're
giving john eastman a platform to go and
talk about his [ __ ] [ __ ]
whitewash story
we shouldn't believe it for a [ __ ]
second [ __ ] john eastman [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
so that's the story of john eastman and
i would encourage you
i would encourage you to make sure i
mean if i were you i definitely wouldn't
go to any kind of conservative
post that are supporting this [ __ ]
and completely
fill up their replies i wouldn't do if i
were you i wouldn't do that
of course my tweet was john eastman knew
what the [ __ ] he was doing
trying to distance himself from the
cheeto dust mobster's delusional big lie
is an attempt to save his own ass
because that's what he's trying to do
here he's trying to save his job
and he's trying to save his law license
he's trying to save his credibility and
his reputation
but ultimately he's trying to save his
[ __ ] freedom here
and the reason why is because john
eastman is going to be deposed
he's going to have a subpoena land on
his desk
and if he doesn't comply with that
subpoena which this may be this may be a
run-up to that situation where more
people are held in criminal contempt of
congress
but if john eastman he's gonna get a
subpoena he's gonna he's gonna be
deposed
he's gonna have to hand over records
of what what what was the what was the
timeline of this memo what was the
intention of this memo what's the
timeline of the intention of this memo
so we're gonna find out more about john
eastman but this is all this is all an
attempt to save his ass and to save his
reputation by him distancing himself
from the cheeto dust mobster
and by by basically saying oh no one no
one in their right mind would believe
what i was saying not even grandpa
poopypants so he's trying to give he's
trying to give an out to donald trump
here too well [ __ ] that [ __ ] that is not
gonna work
your whitewashing of history on january
6 in the lead up in the run up to
january 6
the the attempt of a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
will not work
[ __ ] you we know what happened we saw it
and we can read your [ __ ] memo we can
read it we can read
we can listen to the [ __ ] audio of
john eastman standing on the stage
inciting an insurrection
with the language that he has in his
memo
that he sold to rudy giuliani and
grandpa poopypants
so that way they could overthrow the
government of the united states by
convincing that by convincing themselves
and others that mike pence had the power
to crown donald trump king and dictator
get the actual [ __ ] out of here that is
what happened
it is already publicly known we just
need to know all the [ __ ] details who
called who who pushed who
what what was the [ __ ] intent behind
this
we need to know this [ __ ] and that's
what the january 6 select committee is
there to do
to make sure you're held accountable if
it especially if it's [ __ ] criminal
the other thing i want to know is how
many congress congress people how many
republican congress people
were
were
involved in this memo with eastman
who else knew about this memo beforehand
who else pushed for this memo who else
knew john eastman was going to be on
stage
trying to sell the lie
that that donald trump had won and mike
pence could overturn the election
because mike pence wanted to
and because donald trump wanted him to
who else
who else
who else was involved in this memo
that's what i want to know
so that's the jon eastman story um i
didn't go to the trendy trends yet but
i'm just i'm just scrolling down my feed
hey hey this is this is interesting
have you guys seen this uh the
supporters
the movie that's coming out it's kind of
like a borat style